I made you pick me. I liked your picture. Okay, you have this sad look on your face. I feel sorry for you. Dang
So what happens to me?
Did you think we were gonna have sex?
No, I thought we're gonna hang out maybe get to know each other you
Swerving a little bit back to here going that you step out of the vehicle for me
Go to ground ! Are you serious? Why is he under arrest?
Just get back in the car you going to jail too
What do you want I want a rattle back
Guilt it was self-defense there is nothing back there for us
Within the blackballing class
I'm gonna bend the world
As long as my lady remembers me fondly, that's all I need. Can I be your legacy?
You already are
I think the only thing is Destin